good
morning next morning yes sergeant juan
garcía in the morning for the week from 6:15
in the morning the center's
communications center receives a call about an
accident that involved a double
trailer collision and a
received this
the accident was reported in it
the  state highway 515 and northeast
east the double trailer truck goes north
on the 115
and when I got here on the highway at
night the fbi was
heading west we don't know if he stopped at the
stop before the accident it's for this
moment but it seems that when he left
at 100 15 he was hit by the other
double trailer
in the vehicle that would involve 25
people and the driver of the touch only in
the tro that is in case of the accident
unfortunately 13 people
died from the vehicle were now
york
twelve were killed here in the
accident and  the other was that he went to the
hospital and what about
the driver of the throne who was also
transferred to the hospital with no major
but significant death  arid
because they were taken to the hospital, they
went to three different hospitals, some
went to the center, others came to the
memory of the stepson and the other to the
service hospital, but with this
we are also in communication with the consulate
to try to help them communicate
with relatives to give them  information and
what is happening at the moment the
team the unit that is specialized
in investigating accidents are here
now not everything they need to
determine what happened
so more clearly and they will be here for
quite a few hours until they have everything
they  They need, so this route will be
closed for several hours,
that is to say that all the last ones are
Mexican by a hair,
well, we do not know this if so many are from
Mexico, but to help us, they are
here to help us to determine that
it is done at the moment, we do not know the
nano  everyone's departure
is not now that there were also children
in the vehicle at the moment we do not know
the ed  Also, if there were minors, we
don't know their ages or conditions
for a moment, they don't
take over the lambs,
we don't know this at the moment, they didn't just
make me workers or something like that,
seriously, it
's very early in the investigation, all
this is going to be determined.  As I say,
in the unit, have all the information
they need, they will determine that because of
what happened, however the candidate came out, she
was persecuted by the Holiness before they
say no, there were no other people
involved in this incident,
we do not know if they are all dedicated at
times to this  we are right now
some of me ask you
no that no
my name is juan garcía
the truck was going more
west north south and the truck was going
north in zinc and salt a
little more
then